but what is the latest on this this
standoff well this is your three days of
Maneuvers called Joint sword by the uh
the Chinese and it's to send a Stern
warning according to the Chinese to
Taiwan
um not to move away as they they're
doing and as you say there's been a
standoff between 20 warships along the
median line now the median line is a
sort of unofficial boundary between
Chinese territory and
um and Taiwanese territory and yesterday
we saw 71 aircraft sort of circling
um Taiwan Chinese aircraft of which 45
of them crossed the median line or
crossed another area that uh to the
southwest of Taiwan that's called their
air defense identification Zone it's not
quite into what would be classed as
Taiwanese territory but on the edge of
it that creates an interest what's the
take of the significance of that
touching the median line is is that a
rare occurrence or does it happen from
time to time it happens actually quite
often at the moment and a lot of this is
as I said at the beginning is sending a
message it's all a big information
operation but you using military
equipment and it's all about President
Tai's visit to the United States to
visit senior leaders of the Democratic
and Republican party and more
particularly Kevin McCarthy the speaker
of the house if we remember his
predecessor Nancy Pelosi last year went
to Taiwan to Taipei and that caused real
difficulties and and another surge in
Chinese Maneuvers around Taiwan
um Kevin McCarthy decided not to go
um because he did modern flame things
but it has the meeting hasn't flamed it
anyway
in his Congress when he opened the 20th
Congress in October turned around and
said he would never promise to give up
the use of force and reserves the option
to take Taiwan by all necessary means